now let's get labour's take on all that
from the shadow foreign secretary david
lammy
joins us from central london
now um morning mr lammy uh
so far let's talk about your area of
responsibility first if we may so far
you've essentially supported the
government on its ukraine
policy but you've criticized them for
being distracted by domestic politics
and we'll come to all that in a minute
if they were not so distracted
what more would you want them to be
doing
well look of course it's important that
we stand up to russian aggression
abroad
and in central europe but it's hugely
important that we deal with russian
aggression in our own country and
we have been calling now for months and
months for the government to implement
the russia report that our intelligence
select committee
reported on
we have no register of overseas property
250 000 properties in london owned by uh
overseas entities um they haven't dealt
with the computer misuse act why
they have changed electoral law
to allow limitless donations to
political parties it's hard to
understand they've taken
about five million pounds worth of
donations from russian linked donors
they should give that money back
and so we've been saying that we have to
deal with the dirty money that's
circulating in london london becoming
the laundromat of the world and
embarrassingly president biden conveying
concern
that the sanctions regime that we needed
is comp is compromised because the
government's refusal to deal with that
dirty money problem
okay
i i want to come to that actually
because you've issued a press release
and you've named some of the individuals
that you think
are behind this kind of money but before
we come to that can i just ask you about
ukraine itself
liz trusts when i spoke to her last week
said clearly that the uk should arm a
resistance movement in ukraine if there
is a russian takeover
would you agree with that
well look i was
in kiev just about a month ago now and
it was clear that in kiev they were
hugely supportive of the work that we've
been doing through operation orbital
with their armed services helping them
to train
but of course if it is the case that
russia
chooses to uh incur or invade the
country they will need support and it's
absolutely right that we
support the ukrainians in that defensive
posture because that's the situation
that they will be in
so does that mean that labor would
support sending money and arms to a
ukraine
resistance movement were there to be a
russian takeover
well look this is the ukrainian army
that we've been working with now since
2014 let's remember that
because of the annexing of crimea and
because of that incursion into
the dom pass and the separatist fighting
that's going on already within the
country uh we have been working uh with
those armed forces training them and
supporting them and
nato allies of course want to ensure
that they can protect the integrity of
their country the sovereignty of their
country we said that this would be a
very very bloody battle indeed already
14 000 uh people have died because of
that incursion and just outside the
cathedral there is a wall of remembrance
for all of those young men and women
that have lost their lives uh we tend to
forget that they have already been uh
experiencing this conflict and of course
we must
support them if there is to be a battle
ahead
that that okay so you would support
arming
a resistance movement
resisting russian aggression absolutely
thank you now um
you obviously do want to talk about the
issue of
russian what you call dirty money in
london just to get one thing clear if um
any labour politician or organization
were to be found taking money from putin
or any of his associates you'd want
them to give that money back or be
thrown out of the labour party
i think at this time it's incumbent for
all of us
to be clear about the dangers of
plutocrats kleptocrats and money
laundering in our country the tituation
changed dramatically after
2014
and we should all be cognizant of that
situation it's against that backdrop
that we have challenged the government
on the donations that they have received
yeah i'd like to come to that in a
second i just want to ask you about
something that's actually in your
control which is linked to the labour
party government
but i want to ask you about something
that you can actually make a decision
about which is would labor throw out
anybody who took
uh putin or putin associated money
well what we've asked for for the
conservatives is to give the money back
and yes no no i just asked you about the
labour party i'm going to ask you about
the conservatives but i want to ask you
about load party
yes and i'm responding to you trevor and
i'm saying
that if that is the case the money
should be given back
okay thank you all right well let's
let's talk about the tories and you've
um issued uh press release today and i i
want to look at one of some of the
people that you name in your release um
one of them is uh the ukrainian-born
selenade belvatnik who is the united
kingdom's richest man
and is you say an example of what you
call and i'm quoting here from your
release the widespread presence of
suspect russian money in the uk and you
want the conservatives him to
conservatives to give back the 145 000
pounds he's given them in the last 10
years
look the case is this that we have
individuals in our country who often
have dual nationality
many of those individuals made money
under putin's regime and if you go back
upon the breakup of the soviet union
taking over what were previously
national industries the times today is
reporting the sons and daughters of
people linked to putin
buying property
here in london it's against that
backdrop that it's wrong to change
our election law to say that you can
have limitless donations of course it's
important that we are completely above
board and any money associated with
vladimir putin in his regime should be
given back
does that mean selena blavatnik should
give back should be given back his 145
000 pounds that this comes from your
release
give him give him the money back that's
what we've said okay uh
should um
oxford university also give back the 75
million pounds he gave them in 2010 and
should your own alma mater have harvard
university give back the 250 million
dollars it received from him in the past
decade if this is dirty money
i think we should make a distinction
between political donations to our party
that is the distinction that was made in
the russia report that is the
distinction that was made by the senate
in their foreign affairs committee
report where they were concerned about
the influence of that money on political
decisions of the day so what we're
talking about are political donations
and we must have a system that's
accountable that's transparent and that
is above board that is the basis on
which we are asking the government to
deal with dirty money but that's not
just the labor government doing that our
own
intelligence select committee asked the
government to do this and there's a
range of things that i've set out
overseas property
how we change uh companies house uh and
our just before how we deal with
espionage how we deal with the golden
visas that are okay
because
okay
because you stress the political uh
donations let's just try one one more uh
blavatnik has given money to barack
obama hillary clinton kamala harris and
joe biden will you be telling them that
they should all be giving them that
money back
trevor i i don't think that those
individuals need
advice from me and you know that my
concern is the politics of this country
barack obama shouldn't
dirty
money from
my concern is the situation on our
eastern borders my concern is dirty
money here in london that's the concern
of joe biden it's the concern of our
intelligence committee and that is where
rachel reeves and i uh this morning have
said the conservatives should give that
money back
all right okay let's just return to um
as it were normal politics if if that
phrase can be used about what's going on
right now um
you your leader says he really can't
wait for the prime minister to fall and
you think it's your patriotic duty to
make that happen
um
it seems that there are a lot of tories
who would like to vote for a
uh no confidence motion um
is labour anywhere nearer getting to a
place where it can move that no
confidence motion or is it waiting for
back bench tories to do the job
the number one issue here trevor is that
the prime minister should resign
you know and there's a lot of history
that he could look at he says he's a
great historian chamberlain resigned
when he could not form a national unity
government eden resigned after suez
theresa may indicated she would resign
after a disastrous general election and
david cameron resigned after the
referendum because of the numbers the
majority that the conservatives have
this is an issue for conservative
backbenchers and of course you've seen
many of them indicating that the time
has come for him to step down uh a vote
of confidence well why not give them the
opportunity to vote in the government
and of course labor of course labor have
no confidence in the government but this
is an issue now about boris johnson and
his fitness to govern yeah and allies
uh i get that my enemies are laughing at
him the public are ashamed i get all the
adventures are have lack
it's on that basis that he should step
down trevor i get all that but why
aren't you giving
the
conservative backbenchers and the other
parties the opportunity
to vote for that to happen
[Music]
that's leadership isn't it you know that
you know on the numbers
that we have in the commons within the
opposition we can't make that happen and
that was sealed in the general election
and the result that we have so this is a
matter for the 1922 committee and it's
about boris johnson individually a
confidence measure in the government i
suspect would fail uh if we were to
bring it to the to the floor of the
house at this stage
because it would take conservative
backbenchers voting for it to bring him
down
david let me thank you very much indeed
for your time this morning